So far, we've talked about author-driven visualizations that are typically
linear and have predetermined narratives.
We've also talked about viewer-driven visualizations, that allow viewers to
interact with the data directly to craft their own data story.
I like to call these types of visualizations Choose Your Own Adventure.
There's a third narrative structure,
common in more complex data visualizations called the martini glass.
It's called the martini glass because of its unique shape.
Think of a martini glass set it on its side.
It has a base, a long narrow stem, with a wide mouth.
Viewers start at the base and work through the neck of the martini glass.
Typically through a single path that is author-driven.
When they reach the mouth, the visualization opens up and
allows the viewer to freely explore different paths within the data.
And to tell their own narrative.
This way, it combines with the author-driven and
viewer-driven narrative structures in a single cohesive whole.
Let's look at a few examples.